for most illnesses a vaccine is an
almost guaranteed lifeline
but influenza is different we have very
good measles vaccine we have a very good
rubella vaccine very good the mumps
vaccine
all of these viruses in the population
haven't changed over the last 50 60 70
years
in contrast influenza changes every year
the world health organization estimates
that influenza infects 1
billion of us every year causing up to
650 000 deaths worldwide
vaccines are critical but they're only
around 50
effective because they don't fight every
strain of flu here we are
so scientists around the world are
searching for a shot that fights
different strains of the virus
including some that might not even exist
yet it's really very exciting because
you know that
you are working for something good that
may change the whole
world and the health of many people this
breakthrough would give us lasting
protection against influenza
but it might also help us understand how
we get there with other viruses too
difficulty breathing highly contagious
returning year after year
hippocrates first described influenza in
412 bc
since then the virus has caused annual
epidemics
most notably the spanish flu in 1918
that killed an estimated 50 to 100
million people worldwide
and changed the world in ways that seem
all too familiar today
1918 when the influenza a
h1n1 showed up uh was during a period of
a lot of
problems in the united states at the
time world war one was ongoing at that
time
there was a lot of movement from rural
areas into
cities so at the time we didn't even
know it was a virus
viruses were kind of still being figured
out at the time so it really was not
until the 1930s that we
knew the cause of the 1918 pandemic and
then subsequently
the seasonal epidemics that we would
have every winter
that they realized that that was
actually due to a virus
and so from the 30s it wasn't really
until
the 19th late 1940s and 1950s that
actual vaccines were being used more
regularly
even though there are just three basic
types of flu a b
and c type a which is the most dangerous
for humans
has a surface covered in two main
proteins h
and n there are 18 different types of h
protein
and 11 types of n protein and they
combine to create up to 198 influenza
subtypes
including ones like h3n2 and h1n1
the influence of virus is constantly
changing and so if you
look at a virus on the inside of the
virus
are the genes and genes are just the
recipe the instructions for making more
copies of itself
so if somebody sneezes or coughs
and you happen to breathe that in those
viruses that are in those respiratory
droplets go to the back ear throat
they grab on to the respiratory cells
that are there
they push themselves into the cells and
then release that
those genes that are in there those
genes
it's not one long string of instructions
it's eight
separate strings of instruction and so
there's so much opportunity for that
virus
to mess up in terms of making copies of
itself
it's not a very good editor it really
doesn't have good quality control
in in one way that's bad for the virus
because it makes copies of itself that
may not even
live on they don't even reproduce but
it also means that it can find ways to
get around
your own immunity and ways to get around
vaccines that are being used
and to get around antiviral drugs as
well
[Music]
this genetic shape shifting is known as
antigenic drift
and means that our body can't always
recognize the virus even if we've caught
it or been vaccinated before
but scientists at pharmaceutical company
beyond vax have worked for almost three
decades
creating a vaccine which targets parts
of the virus that don't change
all influenza viruses are different in
their appearance but they are still
considered as influenza because they
have a lot in common
and the what the immune system wants to
do they want to recognize
the virus and to attack it when it
enters the body
so we have to teach the immune system
how the virus looks like so
what we thought will be more effective
and to have a universal vaccine
is to show the immune system and teach
it to recognize
the concept and common denominator of
all influenza viruses
so we constructed a vaccine it is called
m001
it contains nine such conserved
regions from the influenza violence
variations between influenza viruses
usually happen on the surface
but dig a little deeper and there are
similarities in its peptides
short strings of amino acids that are
responsible for how the virus functions
m001 is made up of nine different
peptides that our immune system can
learn to recognize
and fight off in the future one of the
peptides that we selected in our
vaccine is very close to the point where
the virus is entering the cells
so it's like a key and the locality key
is on the side of the virus and the lock
is the entrance to our cell and
if the virus wants to enter the cell and
cause the disease it
enters his key into the lock opens it
and the disease starts to develop
so by our vaccine we block this
key and the virus cannot anymore enter
into the cell
and we prevent the disease so m001 is in
phase three clinical trials
are you feeling nervous about the
results of course i'm worried all the
time i hardly breathe
until we get the outcomes of our pivotal
phase straight trial which is a trial
with over 12
000 participants that was conducted
there in europe
in this trial we injected half of the
participants with
our vaccine and the other half received
placebo which was the
saline and at the end of the trial which
means at the end of this month
we will know how many participants were
ill in the
experimental group that was immunized
with our sin
and how many were ill in the control
group that actually was not immunized
and if the difference would be
high enough then our vaccine works and
they were happy we'll know
if it is safe if it is protected
against the influenza a universal
vaccine like m001 would radically change
the way we make our flu shots
currently for northern hemisphere
vaccines every february the who picks
four strains of influenza which
scientists predict will most likely be
circulating in october
the start of the flu season this vaccine
recipe is sent out to manufacturers
and the majority of vaccines are made
just like back in the 40s
by injecting the vaccine virus into
fertilized eggs
it takes at least six months to produce
the high quantities we need
so we have to really based on what
happened
uh two months before february but we are
not really good at that
unfortunately dr peter pelazi is a
microbiologist
who built the first genetic map of the
influenza virus back in the seventies
the yearly influenza vexing i think is
under appreciated
underutilized so i think there is a
benefit
in taking the vaccine because even if
you get the flu
it was a failure but your disease the
morbidity
is much lower clearly i think i want to
encourage
your listeners to take the current
vaccine the kernel influenza virus
vaccine
as an insurance against whatever might
happen
yeah so it is it is a very safe vaccine
i think it is a very good vaccine
having said that if we want to make a
better vaccine
we have to show that it is at least as
good as
the current vaccine but also that it
really
preempts or knows what the
what the other strains in year three
four five from now on will be
and also the potential new pandemic
strains
dr palesi's team is also part of the
race to create a universal vaccine
like beyond facts they're using an area
of influenza that doesn't mutate
the stem of the h protein on the surface
of the virus
we are redirecting the immune system
towards these conserved regions
and i have to say i can protect
any animal whether it's a mouse whether
it's a ferret whether it's a guinea pig
against any strain so it's using these
con constructs which present the
conserved
domain of the virus i can it works
beautifully in animals
but remember mice are not men ferrets
are not humans i think we make uh
progress
but it is still it is still not there
and i
i can't promise you that uh it will be
two years or three years that
we cannot really put the predict how
long it will take
that we will have such a universal
influence over as vaccine
with disappointing results in the m001
phase three trials
the weight will be longer than some had
hoped but the research and time that's
been invested isn't wasted
far from it could the work we're doing
to find a universal flu vaccine help in
the way that we tackle viruses like
covert 19.
absolutely the other way around too and
so the work that now
with significant resources and speed
being put into covid right now
could have a significant impact on flu
vaccine
choices if you have a system in place
where you can make those kinds of
vaccines
fast as soon as you see an emerging
pandemic influenza you can start making
vaccine immediately
so faster vaccines and so i think we'll
learn a lot about that with the coping
vaccines as well so
all of that together we would love to
see what we're learning with code
be applied to flu because what we're
doing right now with covet is highly
informed by what we were doing with flu
previously what would be the next steps
if we got a universal vaccine what would
be
wonderful is to get to that place where
flu vaccines aren't something that are
just for
middle and higher income countries that
low and middle-income countries globally
have a significant impact of flu every
year but a
program to vaccinate children and
adults every year in a country with
billions of people
is really complicated and can be pretty
expensive
coming up with a simple solution that
can be rolled out
in a programmatic way where it's cost
effective for that country to do it
would have
a significant impact for a better
functioning country